From calorie count to portion sizes,
we wanted to find out all the differences
between Burger King in
the US and in China.
This is "Food Wars."
Hey, it's Joe.
I'm busy working on some
cool new videos for you.
I will not be able to host today,
but I want to introduce
you to my good friend Nico.
I trust Nico's going
to do a fantastic job.
All the "Food Wars"-heads
watching, make her feel welcome.
Take it away, Nico.
Here in China, our Burger King
drinks come in three sizes:
small, medium, and large.
In the US, our Burger King
drinks come in four sizes:
value, which we weren't able to get,
small, medium, and large.
Let's see how much our largest
drink actually contains.
I'm kind of OK with it.
They're lying to me.
Our Burger King fries
also come in three sizes:
small, medium, and large.
Our fries come in four sizes:
value, small, medium, and large.
Let's weigh our largest fries. 120.
140 grams. Liars again.
This is the second lie I've
been told in like five minutes.
I think Joe and Harry
have beef with Burger King
ever since #frygate2020.
They discovered the small and medium sizes
were the same size, allegedly.
Allegedly. I do not want to get sued.
But let's see if both of them
actually do weigh the same.
I don't think that I have to
count every individual fry,
because that is a very big difference.
I think there's clearly
some discrepancies going on.
Just for fun, let's
weigh these value fries.
These are 98.
What's happening?
What's going on at Burger King?
So I guess you can get away
with just ordering a value size
for, like, way less money
if this is what's going on.
Our chicken fries come in one size only
and should contain six fries.
Ta-da.
No way to escape from giving
us the full amount here, BK.
There's only six of them.
Ours is also one size: nine chicken fries.
One, two, three, four, five,
six, seven, eight, nine.
This is the first time
that Burger King hasn't
lied straight to my face.
Let's begin with our beef burgers.
We can start with the King's Collection,
which I guess are BK's premium burgers.
Whereas the Whoppers
are known as Emperors,
but they're cheaper than the kings.
I can just hear the nationalists
starting to get angry already.
How could a king be more powerful
and more expensive than an emperor?
What gives?
You obviously haven't
localized properly, BK.
You need to know your audience.
Beginning with the pastrami Angus.
It's not something that you see very often
here in China to begin with.
So in in Chinese,
the name is called the
"bigmouth Angus burger,"
because the burger itself is
meant to be quite a tall burger.
But this is a very beautiful
burger, and I must say,
I am very impressed that it
has not come to us sloppy
and completely crushed into paste,
which was the case that we found
with other fast-food chains.
I'm not going to name
names. [cough] [bleep]
Very dense.
I did have to open my mouth pretty wide.
And I can't quite taste the pastrami,
but I like that it's there.
Here we've got the classic Angus.
You can also get the spicy version,
which is what I've opted for.
Ooh, ooh.
Oh, that's a spicy fella.
This is actually pretty interesting.
It's not the Sichuan spicy kind of heat
that I've gotten used to here
eating other localized burgers in China,
but this is more sort of a
straight-up, in-your-face heat.
Lot of black pepper, and
the caramelized onions,
oh, they pair very well in this burger.
Introducing the heavy cheese beef King.
So heavy, actually, it even
crushed the box that it came in.
Well, hello. The spicy bamboo
shoots beef chicken Whopper.
That is such a long name.
It came in this box.
These are characters from
a massive game in China
called the Honor of Kings. It's a MOBA.
The company that makes
this bought Riot Games,
which made "League of Legends."
The fact that it has this collab,
I mean, that means something.
I just want to say it tastes very Chinese
in the best possible way.
It feels like I'm in
Southwest China right now,
playing a game of Honor
of Kings and losing badly.
Because otherwise,
how would I have time to eat
burgers if I'm not respawning?
Final member of the King Collection is
the Italian spinach bacon Angus.
Oh, one thing that irks
me a little bit about
bacon in burgers in China is that
they're this kind of bacon. They're wet.
And what's the point of eating
bacon if it's not crispy?
Oh, my God.
BK burgers are so incredibly dense.
They're like the burger
versions of diamonds.
Moving on to our classic burgers.
This is the
king oyster mushroom
beef Whopper Thai basil flavor.
My God, not only are
their burgers mouthfuls,
but so are the names.
You can actually see the oyster mushrooms.
Look, right here.
Let's give this mouthful a mouthful.
It feels like I'm in the gym
about to do some really heavy lifting.
[exhales]
And then [grunts].
Another classic, the
grilled pineapple Whopper.
One gigantic pineapple ring.
If I had two more hands so, oh.
The pork cubes and beef burger.
Who names these things?
The pork cubes that it refers to is
pork neck.
It's a meat lover's heaven, isn't it?
I can do this!
Feeling like my jaw's about to break.
Oh, yes.
Wow.
That is amazing.
This pork neck is just
absolutely delicious.
Moving on to our value section,
we've got the spicy Whopper Jr.
Oh, look at this little guy.
You can also get the
pineapple bacon Whopper Jr.
also in this size.
This is our bacon corner.
So we have the bacon King, and
there is a bacon cheeseburger
and the double bacon cheeseburger.
I really want to taste the bacon King.
That's, like, a big burger
for fast food, right?
That is heavy, too.
My face is bigger,
but it doesn't smell as
good as this burger does.
Kind of tastes like a
burger right off the grill.
This is, like, insane how big they are.
Now let's move on to the Whoppers.
I think these are definitely
Burger King's claim to fame.
It's what they're most known for.
This is the Texas Double Whopper.
This kind of looks like the
Mondo Burger from "Good Burger."
That is not ASMR.
What's the opposite of ASMR?
And the last Whopper we have
is the Impossible Whopper,
which I actually think
tastes pretty delicious.
Like, this looks like a hamburger
from a play food set I had as a child.
It just doesn't look very real.
This looks like a monster.
I do want to take a bite of
the Texas double Whopper,
just because it's got
a lot of stuff in it.
That is so good.
Oh my God, it's really spicy.
And here we have our single
Rodeo Clown King burger.
[camera crew laughs]
Single Rodeo Burger King pounder.
All of them share the exact
same words. It's crazy.
And here we have the
single quarter-pound King
and the Rodeo burger, which I
think has onion rings in it.
I was wrong.
OK, pretend I said the opposite.
So this is the Rodeo burger,
and it's got onion rings
and what looks like sticky barbecue sauce.
It's just a little congealed in there.
I think it could be good.
It's just not very good.
Now let's move on to the
chicken sandwiches, or burgers,
whichever you prefer.
As for chicken, you can
get the chicken Whopper,
coming in classic or spicy flavors.
You can get the grilled pineapple
chicken Whopper as well.
Next we've got the chicken Big King.
Now the Big King is a
collection, and we have beef,
which is not exclusive here in China,
but chicken and fish are.
And it's basically kind
of like a Big Mac in that
there are two patties
and a bun in the middle.
That's a lot of bread.
This here is the fruitwood
grilled chicken burger.
Spicy chicken burger.
The chicken is threatening to escape.
Oh, yeah, the more you chew it, mm.
The more you chew it, the
more flavorful it becomes.
And now I can,
it's almost like a
thermometer in my mouth.
I can,
I can feel the spiciness rising up.
I swallowed just now,
and my saliva is spicy.
We have the crispy chicken sandwich.
But what makes this a
sandwich and this a burger?
I have no idea.
There's also a double version of that,
excuse my lettuce,
that is called the double chicken burger.
So if it's a single, it's
a crispy chicken sandwich,
but if it's a double, then it
just becomes something else.
Anyway, this also comes in
original or rattan pepper flavor.
Here we have the chicken version
of the Italian spinach bacon Whopper.
A surprise for you all,
this is new on the menu.
Da-da-da.
The black cheese and
crispy chicken sandwich.
So this thing is not nori.
This is actually a slice of cheddar cheese
that's been dyed black with squid ink,
because just why not?
So if you thought this
was weird, check this out.
This is the black cheese
and crispy chicken burger.
Most importantly, instead of the bun,
they've replaced it with
two pieces of black cheese.
Mind blown.
I think this is basically
just an excuse for you
to not feel guilty about eating
a piece of spicy chicken by
itself without the bread.
It's basically just there as, like, tissue
to help you eat this thing.
We have two chicken exclusives,
the original chicken
sandwich and the Chicken Jr.
This shape is actually very
unique and pretty iconic.
In a world of circular chicken sandwiches,
this stands out to me.
Usually the chicken sandwiches
I see look like this.
Just you know, nothing special.
But this is special.
BK also offers fish exclusives.
Here we've got the Fish'N Crisp,
which I believe uses a cod fillet.
And of course, the fish
version of the Big King.
And of course, we also have a pork section
comprising of two burgers,
the pork neck and beef burger,
which I took a nice big
chunk out of before.
And the chicken version
of this pork burger.
And here is our fish option, the Big Fish.
This is the smoothest bun I've ever seen.
Look how shiny and beautiful that is.
It's not offensive,
not particularly great.
These are our exclusive snacks
here in Burger King China.
I feel like they're encroaching
on KFC territory a little bit,
because all of this is chicken.
We've got the mala chicken drumstick.
So "mala" literally just
means numb and spicy,
and it's referring to the
Sichuanese style of cooking
with the peppercorn,
which gives you the
numbness and the chili heat.
Oh, wow.
I feel like this is probably
the strongest mala flavor
that I've had thus far on Food Wars.
It's starting to turn my tongue numb.
I'm quite pleasantly surprised.
Here we've got the petite
version, the mala chicken wings.
This here, the King hot
and spicy chicken wings.
Oh, man, I much prefer it
over the mala to be honest.
This is a lot more balanced,
it's more flavorful, it's meatier.
So these are called the
spicy flavor chicken slices.
Apparently it's 4-millimeter thin
slices of chicken breast.
It just kind of looks like mini
chicken nuggets, doesn't it?
This is the chicken box,
which contains a medley of
what we sampled earlier.
So Burger King also has other versions of
the bucket, the box, whatever
you'd like to call it.
They've got the King chicken
bucket, the King bucket,
and the King bucket plus.
They're basically the BK version of
the party bucket or family bucket.
For those of you who
could not get enough of
the black cheese,
you can also get it as a standalone piece.
Just one piece of good old cheddar cheese
dyed black with squid ink.
Oh, BK, you are so funny.
You can always opt for the garden salad.
And here in Chinese it actually says,
"Mama is shouting at you,
telling you to eat more veggies."
And these are our exclusive side options.
We have onion rings.
Don't mind if I do.
They're soggy.
And we also have mozzarella sticks,
which I feel like at this
point are fully congealed
back into their, like, frozen state.
These were supposed to
come with a marinara sauce.
I don't think I got one.
We also have Mott's applesauce as a side,
but they unfortunately ran out.
And here are our exclusive sauces.
We have buffalo, ranch,
honey mustard, and zesty.
I know what pretty much all
of these sauces taste like,
except for zesty.
I'm very confused as
to what this could be.
Just watch this one for you guys,
just so you can see what it
looks like on my skin tone.
This is the most disturbing,
stupid thing I've ever done.
Horseradish-y.
I feel like zesty gives
me like, ooh, zesty.
This is like, ugh, zesty.
It's nasty.
Time for dessert.
We can start with the
Ovaltine King Fusion.
This comes in original strawberry
and brown sugar bubble flavor.
The Ovaltine was the little
sort of brown flakes on top.
That's what tastes like milk chocolate.
Not bad. It's not as sweet
as I thought it would be.
Ovaltine King Fusion,
brown sugar bubble edition.
Very elusive these days.
Where are they?
Ah, here we go.
Mm, delicious.
Once upon a time,
this was the Hokkaido flavor
ice cream waffle cone.
It tastes like melted ice cream.
I can't tell.
If you say it's Hokkaido,
I'm none the wiser.
This is the crispy
chocolate and nuts sundae.
Häagen-Dazs, Ben and Jerry,
get out the way, BK's in town.
Look at that. That looks luxe.
Look at how much chocolate is in here.
This is basically half a bar
of chocolate in ice cream.
There's nothing that
could be better than this.
I think it's peanut.
I'm not sure. Who cares?
Oh, it's delicious.
And the strawberry pulp sundae.
Actual strawberry in the sundae.
Color me impressed.
Now this pie comes in
two different flavors:
dark chocolate or mango and coconut.
Let me check which one this is.
I think it's a telltale sign.
I think it's probably the chocolate.
Deep-fried chocolate, what could go wrong?
These are called crispy thick milk bars.
It's creamy, but it doesn't
really taste like much.
This is the soft mochi ice cream.
And it comes in two flavors,
strawberry yogurt and salted egg.
Wow.
It's kind of like a custard.
Oh, this kind of tastes like
what would happen if you took
the heart out of a moon cake
and liquefied it and just drank it.
Oh, my God,
I think I'm seeing stars from
my blood sugar spiking. Oh.
Let's talk about desserts.
At Burger King in the US,
you can get a soft-serve cup,
a soft-serve cone, or
the Hershey's sundae pie.
This was one of my favorite
things ever as a kid.
I would always get it every
time we went to Burger King.
Look at this.
It literally says yum on every
side, because it's that good.
They look exactly the
same as when I was little.
That is so delicious.
These are the exclusive drinks
on the Burger King China menu.
Looks weird, doesn't it?
It just looks like 7Up.
But this is actually coconut-flavored
lemon sparkling drink.
Peach-flavored oolong tea.
This is the brown sugar boba milk tea.
You can get this hot or cold.
And also, if you take away the boba balls,
it'll just basically become
the Hong Kong-style milk tea,
which you can also get hot or cold.
The crispy chocolate snow-top milk tea.
You can also get Ceylon tea,
which is just black tea,
or hot or cold soy milk, which this is.
You can get juice too,
grapefruit juice and mixed-berries juice.
Next we have the King coffee collection.
And this is just honestly
the cutest cup ever.
You can get your latte or your flat white,
your hazelnut latte, or cappuccino
in this very, very cute squat cup.
Or if you don't like being cute,
you can just opt for a
regular-sized Americano.
Drink exclusives in the US include
Coke zero, Sprite zero, Barq's root beer,
Dr Pepper, Fanta orange,
Mellow Yello, Powerade zero,
High-C fruit punch, and
High-C pink lemonade.
It's a fast food restaurant,
so of course they also offer
milkshakes and frozen beverages.
We have a vanilla milkshake,
a chocolate milkshake,
an Oreo milkshake,
a chocolate Oreo milkshake.
This is a frozen Fanta wild cherry.
And this is supposed to be a frozen Coke,
but it's another frozen Fanta wild cherry.
We've been putting the
people at Burger King
through a lot today, so
some mistakes were made.
They also supposedly offer
a strawberry milkshake,
but that wasn't available
at our Burger King.
[bleep] has a better vanilla milkshake.
All right, let's try this
frozen Fanta wild cherry.
Is this, this is basically
just a slushy, right?
That's very good.
These are Burger King China's
exclusive breakfast menus.
OK, so just like McDonald's and KFC,
Burger King also does
a pretty decent breakfast
menu here in China.
Not quite as extensive as KFC,
and nowhere near as
exhaustive as McDonald's,
but what Burger King has over both of them
is the Croissan'wich.
I love croissant sandwiches.
Although it's kind of weird how in China,
they're not called by their actual names,
but they're called croissants.
So this is the standard Croissan'wich,
or as we call it here in China,
the pork, egg, and cheese croissant.
Next, we have the pastrami
and scrambled egg croissant.
In Chinese, we would call it yangqi,
which kind of means like
Western style of BK.
I mean, obviously it's Western style,
but the fact that you have
pastrami and scrambled egg,
this combination just
seems very, very foreign
to Chinese culture.
And I think in a cool way, this is great,
just staying true to BK's roots.
Mm, I love pastrami.
What do we got here?
The beef, egg, cheese croissant.
And last but not least
in our croissant series, butter croissant,
which is just ...
All right, BK, you made
this a seasonal menu item.
I don't understand what
it has to do with seasons.
It's literally just two pieces
of your croissant bread.
This is the double egg and beef burger.
Two eggs with two beef patties
sandwiched in between.
No bread whatsoever.
There is no way you can safely
get away with eating this
without making a mess of yourself.
Now on to your more standard fare,
the grilled beef cheese muffin.
You can also get this grilled
beef, cheese, egg muffin.
Oh, now we have something special.
The tamagoyaki and fruitwood flavor
grilled chicken muffin.
Look at that.
Mm.
Oh, this is delicious.
Well, I highly recommend it.
And if you don't want beef in your muffin,
you can get it as a cheese egg muffin.
If you don't want egg nor beef,
then you can get it as
a grilled pork muffin.
BK also has an assortment
of breakfast wraps.
The scrambled egg and cheese sausage wrap.
Beijing-style roasted chicken wrap.
No leek. Just the cucumbers
and the tianmian sauce.
We're missing the last item
on the holy trinity of
the Beijing-style wrap.
You know, it's inoffensive.
That's all I can say.
This is something special.
Salted egg yolk chicken wrap.
The salted egg yolk is actually smeared
all over the chicken here.
Wow, that's very ingenious of BK.
There's no mistaking that salted egg, wow.
Texture-wise, it's like,
it's an egg yolk that has been matured.
Kind of like a fine vintage
egg, if that makes sense.
And last but not least,
we've got the mixed vegetable
and roasted chicken wrap.
And of course, we've got to have congee.
Two types, this is century
egg and this is salted egg.
Give the century egg a try.
Whoo.
Oh, yeah, that's pretty strong.
There's a very, very fine
line between tasty and stinky,
and century egg firmly
straddles that line.
I've never had salted egg
yolk in a congee before.
Congee's not my favorite breakfast item,
but I think with this kind of flavoring,
like, yeah, I can dig it.
And of course, on every
single breakfast menu,
there's going to be crispy
Chinese cruller, the youtiao.
They all look the same
no matter which fast food chain you go to.
BK also has a sunny-side-up egg,
although again, you can't
really tell where the sun is.
Ho ho, this is pretty interesting.
The bean paste glutinous rice balls.
We call them matuan,
which kind of means sesame pile, mound.
These have a really interesting history.
They originated in the Tang dynasty
over 1,000 years ago
and were served up in
the imperial kitchen.
And actually, you'll find that
a lot of traditional Chinese desserts,
especially here in Beijing,
were originally served to the emperor.
The sort of stuff that we eat now
would have been the crème de
la crème back in the old days,
centuries ago, when emperors ruled China.
History in a mouthful.
I'd say it's OK.
It's probably not the tastiest
sesame mound I've ever had,
but, you know,
this isn't made for emperors,
because otherwise it'll
be [clicks tongue].
Off with your head.
Egg bacon pie.
Oh, that's pretty tasty.
The nostalgia's coming back in.
I just remember growing up in the UK
and then going down to Greggs
and getting a nice pasty
in the morning, oh.
I've actually never had
Burger King breakfast.
In the US, our breakfast sandwiches
all come with different variations of
sausage, bacon, ham, egg, and cheese.
And they come in either a
croissant, biscuit or melt form.
We couldn't get the melt form,
but we do have the
croissant and the biscuit
in the loaded versions.
Loaded just means that they
come with all of the toppings.
They look like they're about to burst.
So I believe that's true.
In America, this is a biscuit.
The salt that just got into,
I'm like, I felt all
the moisture in my body
just disappear with that one bite.
That was crazy.
Here are all the different
breakfast sandwich combinations
that you can make at
Burger King in the US.
So you can also get
the Egg-Normous burrito
or its baby, if you don't
want that much of a burrito
before like 10 a.m.
We also have sweeter breakfast options,
like these pancakes with the sausage
and the French toast sticks.
It literally feels like I
am chewing gum right now.
That is crazy how stretchy
and bouncy it is right now.
They smell a little old,
like they were just refried.
It's also chewy, just like the pancakes,
but a lot less disturbing in the mouth.
So Burger King entered China in 2005,
which actually makes it late to the game.
KFC and McD's had already been here
for a decade by that point.
And Chinese consumers know
what Western fast food is like already.
BK cultivates a slightly different image,
one of slightly more prestige.
And you'll find them
mostly in major cities,
top-tier cities like Beijing, Shanghai,
less so in smaller cities.
I feel like in the US,
Burger King has the reputation
of being somewhat fresher
when it comes to ingredients.
Maybe it's considered
on the more fresher side
when it comes to American fast food,
even though it's probably not.
It's pretty funny.
In the past, Burger
King has been criticized
for its bad customer service,
for its rude servers.
And the main thing was you
couldn't even complain,
because they didn't have
a complaints hotline.
So they're kind of like,
take it or leave it.
Convenience, speed of service,
that totally depends on
your specific Burger King.
Is it fast food still? Yes.
You still get the food in
around 10 to 15 minutes.
It's just, will you be
getting what you ordered?
Who knows?
That's part of the fun.
I would say that Burger King,
out of McDonald's and KFC,
is the least localized.
And so they're cultivating
maybe the image of being
a gourmet burger joint,
a sort of a go-between
regular fast food chain
and an actual gourmet burger restaurant.
When it comes to how they
adapt to local taste,
I feel like there's nothing
that special on the menu.
It's pretty normal American fast food.
They did have that one
special Texas Whopper,
which, I've never been to Texas,
so I can't really speak
on how accurate that is.
But it tasted really good.
So in terms of competition,
Burger King is actually fifth in China,
behind KFC, McDonald's,
Wallace Burger and Chicken,
which is a local brand,
and Dicos, another local brand.
McDonald's has to be Burger
King's biggest rival.
As we're filming this in early May,
we've gotten word that Burger King is
closing around 300 to 400 locations.
A Whopper is 27 yuan. That's $3.92.
In the US, a Whopper costs $7.89,
which is an 101.3% price increase
compared to China's Whopper.
Make it a meal with a medium
fry and a medium drink,
and the price goes up to
40 yuan, which is $5.80.
Add a medium fry and
a drink to your order,
and that brings the price up to $11.99,
which is an 106.7% increase in price.
And if you want to upgrade to large,
then that's 44 yuan, which is $6.38.
Make it a large in the US, and
the price goes up to $12.59,
which is a 97% increase in price.
Just in general, I've
found that Burger King
tends to be slightly more
expensive than McDonald's and KFC.
China's Burger King doesn't share
its nutritional information,
but here are a few noteworthy moments
from the last couple of years.
In 2020, Burger King
apologized to its customers
when it was reported that
some of their locations
had sold expired food.
So a Burger King in Nanchang,
which is a major city in eastern China,
had used expired ingredients
to make its burgers.
And get this, there was
actually video footage of staff
replacing the date labels
on the expired bread
with new ones.
And another Burger King
in exactly the same city
did the same thing with expired chicken.
Burger King responded with, and I quote,
"Our mismanagement has betrayed
the trust of consumers to Burger King,
and we express our deepest
apologies for this."
End quote.
This caused China to probe further
into other US fast food chains
like KFC and McDonald's.
Burger King, along with
McDonald's, was sued last year
for using PFAS,
or "forever chemicals,"
in their packaging.
Forever chemicals?
It's in my body forever?
Consumer reports found PFAS in
the French toast sticks bags,
Whopper wrappers, and chicken nugget bags.
We ate like two out of
those three things today.
Oh, my God.
PFAS are chemicals that
are hard to break down
and last a long time,
which are not good for the environment.
And PFAS exposure has been linked
to health problems in humans.
Burger King has responded
in saying, quote,
That's not soon enough.
Is it in my food or not?
Is it, like, touching the food?
Is it in the gloves?
Is it in the hats?
Is it in this little crown
that I've been wearing all day?
I'm so stressed out.